you're very passionate about clean tech
you've made a lot of investments here
some people would say that you know
investors like you and John Doerr made a
mistake by going too far into this field
what have you learned from it and what
is your response to that clean tech is
an important area climate change is an
important risk now I view climate change
no different than I view Homeland
Security nuclear proliferation terrorism
they're all risks society faces and we
should insure against them now how much
of our gdp do we spend insuring against
foreign attack national defense Homeland
Security we should treat climate change
the same way it's a business decision on
how much insurance to buy we should
encourage new competitive technologies
to come up and then stop supporting them
when they get to a certain size it's
time to stop supporting wind maybe even
solar should be the subsidies should
start to decline really we've done okay
in clean tack we probably have six
companies that could be worth a billion
dollars still but I'd rather try and
fail than fail to try something that's
really important